bene i ragazzi ragazze ben ritrovati in
questo nuovo video sono by j oggi sono
con laurentiis per due partite oltre di
pesce inran che vogliamo fare qualcosa
di decente
innanzitutto se fossi negli avversari io
sceglierei un nome un attimino più
fattibile tutto è bellissimo
questi secondo me volano oppure la
lisciano può essere per l'attenzione che
la partenza per loro non è male chiedo
pietà dando sfogo ma come tiro male oggi
va bene allora niente magari non
leggiamo i nomi agli avversari prevale
arrivar i vari non lo tocca a lui non la
tocca lui mi ha distrutto e ha distrutto
mi ha distrutto vi ho passato aiuti
soppani caldo tiro io no ho provato
anche andare in anticipo per toglierla
labbra che ho detto avermi mette in
mezzo
beckham e allora vado perché anticipato
che proseguirà tutti
no perché pensavo che l'ha toccata non
ho toccato perché ti non so che tipo di
no perché tutti voi e bella bella bella
questa è bella questa bella queste belle
a bari dai questo grigio comprensivo
numero da 1 a 1
direi meritato per come stiamo giocando
è che dai 10 per loro almeno almeno pari
a meno almeno pari a un bel tiro diretto
dei vecchi che incredibile che non
volevo fare ma va bene che tira di nodi
sopra massa trapasso lì e non ci sono
perché era il tubo però la prendo lo
stesso che c'era c'era ce l'hanno
bravo ma perché dobbiamo prenderle
traverse ma perché ma perché è bello
bello
niente non si può segnare ora non so
perché non è possibile non è possibile
taglia giampiero intagliato punto
dall'inter partita è questa ragazza che
partita e non ho mai no no no no e
allora ce l'hai ce l'hai o non ce l'hai
non ho turbo posso sognare sogna
comminatogli più o meno male
belli seagate nyse d'autore riavviata
coloro sono destabilizzati ciao agli
anno a barbato fortissimo di fondo ma
bravo e prendo questo bravo bravo
madonna tocchet in arrivo c'è il
bellissimo aspetto il suo tocco vado
dietro vado dietro dice così va bene 2 a
1 praga 21 sudato qua e sudato e questa
è un'altra mappa che odio tantissimo
no veramente anch'io che sta qua non so
perché dark avengers tra l'altro brava
la mancata e nostra un bel controllo
avanzano i ragazzi italiani che schifo
di gino ma non tutto che tiene ci sono
altre che ci sono malate passaggio si
intendono i due si intendono questo è il
real madrid lo score anche i buttiamo
subito il secondo è fake è infatti se la
piglia stavolta l'ho letto ma viene dato
veramente in fake pensavo oppure ha
sbagliato non lo so vediamo
non ne ho idea non lo so cosa ha detto
prego prendetevi questo gol come se
niente fosse visto che adesso iniziamo a
fare sul serio ci distruggono non si sia
esattamente non fortissimo
[Applauso]
bello bravissimo madonna sono morto 26
immolato per la squadra va bene vediamo
che faccio
oh mio dio mi chiamo io ti tocchi posso
provarci leggero leggero al centro ken
mamma mia no ora paramore no no no no
come mamma mia ragazzi orribile quanto
detto ma meno componente figo è
veramente figo perché la volevo trip
llarme di tutti invece niente sito sono
molto forza arrivare fino a un certo
punto di sicuro non ti faccio i
controlli strani appello non lo bancano
durello anche lui bello tutti gol è vero
non ci credo il gol sono felice mi
attraversa io non ho nè di controllo di
una tra è sempre traversa portò sempre
traversa guardali però niente male
un 4 a 1 non si rendono i ragazzi perché
ci credono e io li rispetto
missione però la controlla e confuso se
un grande un grande ci agevola
abbandonata perchè lui non può tagliare
22 22
l'ex mister of hope i gnr proprio loro
che ci sfidano ragazzi allora oggi siamo
fire secondo me potremmo anche io la
butto lì porto sfiga ma altre vittorie
su tre portiamoci sfiga
chissenefrega ecco la partenza subito
loro maranello ramello è allora giocato
ma mica te la lupo dai poeti sono
riuscito non so rischio impatto per ogni
caso il messaggio di un salta non salta
la rubano alla rustica
ma dai
niente stile
tanto poi scoperto che non serve a
niente perché non dipende da quanto
vinci le partite
nono posto a vincere non voglio né punti
non servono a niente arrivo perfetto
finiscila tu buono il passaggio guarda
guarda allora visto che è tutto qua
tutto nella mia testa ha detto continuo
andare ma perché abbiamo fatto colare se
abbiamo meno tempo hanno meno tempo
perché dove c'è tutto così dove andare
tutto calcolato nei capi pensati proprio
per 91
mi dissocio la forca ma come cacchio
triplo attacco drillo bomber e colorati
che tiro giusto così
non è vero perciò la fine aumentavano
dan ci credo nella tolta perché tiene
perché tenuto arabella li confondono
facente entra scherzato si vuole
definitivo dei ragazzi per chiuderla ma
non ce la fanno
no c'è l'altro c'è l'altro a loro o mio
dio ha segnato lui e trapasso
e roba giorni bill non glie l'ho tolta
miss social è la mia bèla mai lasciare
spazio ai ragazzi che li puniscono
proprio loro non arrestato il minuto 46
vogliono giocare va bene ci provano
vabbè ci provano ma ma ma ma va va tutta
tu non è male forse fuori di poco questa
ce l'hai
c'è la foppa accaduto perché hanno
subito poi del tuo allenamento lì ma non
volevo fare rimbalzi sinceramente lo
mette alle basse invece è stato un mix
di culo sinceramente tutto calavena
precalcolato sempre sempre che se non a
tutte le quattro ragazze ragazzi tre su
tre ore ma mi sa che forti sembra vi sia
piaciuto vi ringrazio per la visione
ragazzi come sempre stata anche al
canali da british che in descrizione e
noi ci vediamo iscritti al canale è
pesato su mi piace
e magari provate a essere calcolatori
gol come lo siamo noi che ricaviamo da
due ore prima
mica stiamo facendo finta e ci diamo
come sempre la ragazza
[Musica]